[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
q and a pet extravaganza
we are going to answer your super chat
questions yes we are
yes here we go here we go uh as has
become
our tradition we will start by answering
some of the questions that came in
episode 56
before moving on to the ones that came
in today
just watched your debate with dawkins
where would you draw the line at what
can and cannot reasonably be considered
an extended phenotype
and why wow that's a
tough question yes i know where would
you draw the line as to what
can or cannot be see there's no hard and
fast line
yeah i think the thing is the real
question is what does selection see and
what does selection not see so this idea
of extended phenotype is dawkins
concept that well if you take the
shallow end you've got genes that move
through time
by organizing molecules into bodies that
do things that advance the genes
interest
right nobody finds that controversial
dawkins point is
that bodies organize the world outside
them in an analogous
and analogous way that advance the
gene's interest and so in extreme cases
you know a beaver will cut down trees
that will block
a waterway that will create a habitat
that causes the beaver to be able to
you know leave generations of
descendants and this is the example
this is one of the examples but maybe
the most salient example that he uses in
his book of the same name the extended
phenotype
and he has i don't know if he still
feels this way but for for
decades i believe he felt that extended
phenotype was his biggest and most
important contribution to science i
think he still does yeah
um this is a book from 1981 maybe 82
something like that something like that
in any case the point then is where
does the analysis become absurd you know
you know as a footprint an extended
phenotype
right presumably not because it's not
meaningfully so
could a footprint be an extended
phenotype but of course could be in
a certain context so the question isn't
where do you stop extending the analysis
the question is where
is the noise so great relative to the
signal that selection can't see it and
therefore can't operate to refine it
that's
the question that we're after so anyway
there's no
obvious place to draw that line but
that's it's not it's not about where we
want to put the definition it's about
where selection has access to something
so this one uh is a link
with a question why is this allowed to
continue it's very revealing and long
read
jim james lindsay posted on twitter what
are your thoughts uh
so oh where
um it's it's this it's
lockdownskeptics.org
uh and it
i think this is it yeah um
written by sebastian friebel a former
parliamentary advisory to the german
bundestag
on 17th of november 2020
and he raises a number of concerns
in this i have only skimmed it i don't
know if you've had a chance to look at
it at all
um so we are not in any way i
suggest yeah so we are in no way
suggesting that um we
we are not attesting to the veracity
here or saying what we feel overall
um but there are some things in here
there's one quote here we go
um recently bundestag president xiaobo
even spoke about this himself with
astonishing openness when he said quote
the corona the corona cry the corona
crisis is a great opportunity
in the crisis resistance to change is
diminished we can now bring about the
economic and financial union that we
have so far failed to achieve by
political means
yikes uh yeah yikes exactly and so you
know could
um could someone with completely good
and pure intentions have said that
yes um in the context of
other changes that are afoot is that
most generous interpretation
uh the best one that we should the most
likely act to be accurate one going
forward i don't think so
so i can't really say much more about
this but um
should we should we be concerned about
how
uh states and um even larger governments
might take advantage of the resistance
to change
that will happen to people after months
and months and months of not being able
to do what they are accustomed to being
able to do yes yes we should
yeah i would say um the questions are
separable what is the reasonable thing
to do with respect to covid
and to what use might
people put this crisis in which
we have a right not to be
uh modified in this way now i'm not
saying that there isn't some opportunity
in the fact that we have discovered
that lots of things that we thought you
know that
going to work uh is not what we once
thought it was and that that might
allow us to change things at this point
now that we've discovered that
so there is a benign version of this but
i do have the sense
that the massive transfer of wealth that
is taking place
between for example
big businesses which are in a position
to withstand kovid
and small businesses which are not
is something that
is going to be leveraged and to the
extent that it is going to be leveraged
it's also going to create skepticism
of very reasonable measures that we can
and should take
to prevent the spread of disease so
anyway
it's a it's a very frightening
landscape in which it's very hard to
have a conversation about
yeah the biology separate from the
political context
and uh i feel like very few are getting
it right no and i guess
just one more thing on this um the virus
itself is a selective force on humanity
and the different responses to the virus
in various places is a selective force
on the populations on which those are
being imposed
and some of them are presumably
necessary due to the virus and some of
them
are ill-advised and some of them are
well-intentioned but uh badly
implemented
um but selective forces all
and one of the ways that we saw and you
know i i am not at the moment
going to say whether or not i think it
was conscious and
and um imagined well in advance or
simply opportunistic but
the fact that the the protests after the
death of george floyd that became
enduring and became riots in many places
happened with the
severity that they did is um
in no small part i am certain to
lockdown fatigue
and so there was a selective force that
was being responded to
that allowed black lives matter and
other organizations
to get people to spill into the streets
in
great far greater numbers than would
have been possible i think
absent not the virus but the responses
to the virus again some of which were
absolutely necessary and some of which
weren't and i'm not here gonna
go into all the distinctions between
those yep
okay next question um is
is a lot of things uh it came in at the
end last time
at a high dollar amount so i'm going to
read it with the caveat that
there's a lot of things here
dr mike eden question mark and can you
explain the effect of u.s money gambled
in offshore books on the 2020 election
and why markets haven't settled on the
outcome and how close is eric to solving
the speed of light problem
please convince joe rogan and jon
stewart to run for 2024
wow that's a lot of that's a lot that's
a lot of stuff yeah
um i think we respond to one of these
yeah
uh dr mike eden is a perplexing
phenomenon
um i am concerned about
not only the implications of what he has
to say
which are i feel it is
likely he is incorrect but it is
difficult to spot
why and that has me
um more interested in the analysis than
i would otherwise be
the um some people don't know what
you're talking about
i'm trying not to get us kicked off of
youtube okay
and so in any case it is
somehow we have to figure out how those
small number of voices that you can
trust and i hope that we are among them
can discuss the things that need to be
discussed openly without being shouted
down by all sides that are trying to
sell
some sort of politicized version
of the truth and we are headed for uh
a catastrophe surrounding the
analysis of where we are with respect to
kovid
what is reasonable to do what is not
reasonable to do what the cost
benefit analysis of reasonable measures
are
and i should say this is going to get
worse
with the vaccine the questions
surrounding the vaccine if you think
they are simple you are not
understanding
the landscape of this vaccine in the
world that it is
being introduced into and so anyway
i don't know how we talk about that in a
world where
the sword of damocles hangs over every
channel
and there is no court in which to appeal
and
establish that you are in fact behaving
reasonably
but we have to figure out a way because
i do think
a proper analysis is something that you
are entitled to
that it will actually materially
potentially alter the way you
inter-intersect these questions and that
you know spooking everybody so we can't
talk about it so that you have only
the official version to go on as uh
is unfair to you and everybody else so
that's right anyway
um yeah so and we have several vaccine
questions coming up so we'll get back to
that okay
uh you are cordially invited once covet
is at approximately handled level of
control to a dungeons and dragons game
in minneapolis with a bunch of 30 to 40
year olds
not pc and with good beer actually i'm
not sure if en
stands for uh in but
anyway thank you for the invitation yes
i am told that dungeons and dragons is
where
it's at so i hadn't heard minneapolis
invoked this is a particular invite oh i
know yeah
but um you played a little dandy as i
could right a little bit tiny bit a
little bit
yeah oh um i meant to ask zack this can
you enable closed captioning don't know
if it's in your control it's not perfect
but can help this helps me learn
love what you bring um i think it's
usually on
and it got uh d it got turned off
not not by our amazing producer our 60
year old son zach but by
the powers that be at youtube is that
right uh it's officially on
i don't know
okay so this is a question from last
time and a couple i saw a couple of
people said that
a few videos didn't have closed
captioning we always do turn it on
um are interested to hear if it's
somehow not working but
um but ultimately we don't have control
somehow even though we should
okay first question from last hour
regarding still life exercises the
purpose so we talked about um
what still life paintings might be about
in
episode 56 i believe regarding still
life exercises the purpose is highly
analogous to that of tinkering
take complex forms for instance fruit
environments bodies etc
and simplify them down to more basic
heuristic tools that can be easily
replicated from memory
in this way artists learn to internalize
their subjects within a visual library
comprised of a limited set of principles
think of it like an artist's alphabet
made up of lines shapes colors
compositions etc
this is so beautiful and it i i took a
fair amount of art i did a fair amount
of
even 2d art when i was younger and
that was never said to me and i never
intuited it and
it would have brought a whole new
meaning and frankly
intrigue and excitement to to those i
mean i feel the same way
about um now i play i played classical
piano for many many years and
fully a quarter of my practice day every
day for a half an hour out of every two
hours of practice
was scales and arpeggios and and various
just you know
getting what you know there's not really
muscle memory but you know getting the
muscle memory in your hands
and you can still make it beautiful and
recognize that you're
building the library um but for me as a
musician it was never it was never
explained to me at all and i
never heard that for 2d art either i
just find this description amazing yeah
i find it amazing too but i also it
challenges the very model that i
presented so i'm
wondering whether it is in fact accurate
remind us what the model you presented
was
basically that painting
a bowl of fruit got you
it was basically a skill generating
exercise now
this model is consistent to that point
but my point was there was actually a
bowl of fruit
and that the person was painting it
before it rotted yeah
that's not inconsistent with this no it
is because what this person is saying is
that they are doing it from memory
and that knowing what a banana looks
like in an orange looks like
i don't i don't read that this way at
all simplifying them down to more basic
heuristic tools that
can be easily replicated from memory um
so you're building a visual library
comprised of a limited set of principles
well i'd be curious i do read it as from
memory
but i agree with you it the way it's
written it could mean
uh building that skill from an actual
and
certainly anecdotally the the 2d art
that i took um
always had the object that you were
expected that's would be my expectation
um anyway i'd be curious
all right um we have a few vaccine
questions here
um i'm just going to ask i'm going to
read all three of them and then i'll go
back through individually just so we
know it's coming
sure mrna vaccines that is messenger rna
vaccines are unknown agents with very
high potential for long-term effects
specifically focused on reproduction
at cellular and species levels plus big
pharma is using
it says marine i think it means murian
which is mice brain cells
to culture mrna vaccines will you take
next question is please steel man the
position of refusing the first
iterations of the vaccine
from a concerned medical professional
who works in a city hospital system
whose concerns are heavily echoed
thank you and the third vaccine question
that we got this hour
was it is disturbing that with covid
vaccines we have no clarity on duration
of immunity
post-vaccination transvisibility or if
any of the vaccines will protect against
mutated strains of covet 19.
so yeah um i'm not sure what to do with
this because this is a discussion i very
much want to have but again
the sword of damocles yeah right
and we did we did have this discussion a
bit i don't remember it was episode 56
or episode 55 we did talk about
vaccines specifically yep but the
problem is
the question of will you take it
and should one take it yeah is far more
complex than i believe we are allowed to
discuss
and i think this is just purely
analytical that
there is no politics that need to be
here or should be here
but that the following thing is almost
certain to unfold
there is a conflict between your
individual interests
and public health okay the game
theory does not support
the public health conclusion and those
who are focused on the public health
conclusion
then end up misleading the public about
the truth regarding
safety etc in order that the behavior of
people
comes closer to matching the public
health evaluation
now in a world which looks like we're
lying to you
well it can looks like they're lying to
us is what
i agree yes the the people making the
prescriptions about
what everyone should be doing right are
often
often end up in a position of lying
whether or not they know it
yes they're lying um
and frankly i don't even think
i think many of them are lying for what
they feel is a good cause
but that they are not even justified in
uh that escape because in effect what we
have is a system of perverse incentives
in which um they are doing uh the
bidding
of uh an unholy phenomenon in the market
so anyway i don't want to get caught i'm
not going to lie like they do
i i also do recognize though that
discussing
the conflict between the individual
health and the public health
perspective will result in people
biasing towards the individual health
perspective which does have costs it
will kill people
and so you know um how the hell can we
get to a place
where we can properly have this
conversation so that we can hold
all parties to account for their portion
of this disaster and figure out what the
proper collective response is to it
governmentally that's what we are
supposed to be doing
and the idea that we want to shut down
certain people who want to point out
hey actually that thing you're talking
about is a lie and you haven't protected
people
so you're steering them into that lie is
actually steering them into danger
that doesn't have to be there right so
anyway i don't know how we do this
yeah i don't i don't either um i will
say anecdotally that i actually had
conversations with two different
doctors medical doctors this week about
this
uh who i was seeing for for other
reasons and i
i just asked them what's uh
what's it looking like for you in your
particular institution they're in two
very different institutions one of them
a very big
university hospital situation one of
them a small practice
what's the situation for you when do you
think you're going to see it i know
you're excited about
being able to take it as soon as you can
and i got wildly different responses
from these two doctors both of whom i
see and you know i only see doctors who
i who i respect
um but uh one of them is just you know
gung-ho
excited thinks it might happen this
month and you know ready
ready to move on and ready to get
everyone vaccinated absolutely as soon
as possible and
she in this case uh is um you know
eager to sign up and the other one um
is not at all convinced um that
for one thing uh that the
all the healthcare professionals should
be the first wave of guinea pigs
for largely untested vaccines
and this doctor also pointed out that
apparently the elderly populations have
not been in any of the
clinical trials so far so we actually
have almost no
information we basically have no
information on how
how older people will be affected by
these vaccines
but of course the people who are at
greatest risk of dying from this disease
should be first in line or you know at
the top of the list
um if if it's safe
but we don't know well i hate to say it
we we do know it's not safe we do not
know that it does harm
and the distinction has to do with what
the amount that we do not know about the
vaccine yet and cannot know
yeah right everything having been done
right and the signs being positive
doesn't tell you that there isn't a
long-term consequence here that we don't
yet know about
um so anyway let's leave it at that and
figure
some way to have this conversation where
we are not
um placing our entire livelihood in
jeopardy over it
yeah um
yeah so i think is there anything else
okay we'll just we'll leave we'll leave
the vaccine questions there
um this is just a comment we'll be
watching while enjoying a cup of joe for
my new dark horse podcast coffee mug
i'm happy to support your channel and as
always i'm looking forward to an
entertaining and informative show
thank you excellent this one
well this is news to me what is and i
don't know if it's true
what is the evolutionary effect of the
current state of global male population
of sunning one's balls hint it increases
testosterone and hair growth
on one's noggin wait what
it's news to me look i know some people
are involved in some weird stuff and i
even maybe i yeah i never had balls i
imagine it might feel good
i think you don't get burned it would
feel vulnerable and yes that that
burning thing
that would be a real concern um
first of all i think if you're sunning
your balls you probably have too much
time on your hands maybe we all do
at this point um i don't know
i mean baby you have time and privacy
help i hope you have privacy if you're
sending your balls
but i don't understand really what's
being asked here the evolutionary effect
so i mean the person has said what he
you have to pursue testosterone or has
read
it does so um we we don't know
that that seems unlikely on the other uh
you know
increasing testosterone like what what's
there it's sperm
which aren't then you know you're not
then getting a germ soma
germline somaline transfer of
information between the sperm that are
currently
in your testicles and somatic tissue
that
may or may not be increasing uh
production of testosterone
right i mean right i i just don't
i don't even know global male population
what is the global male body how is that
different than global population
well um the other half of the population
doesn't have balls to sun
right but the current state of
global male
popul i don't understand the question
okay um and we we
don't imagine this would be true i mean
are they asking about will there be more
people
and if so why is mail next to population
if they are asking what is the effect of
an increase in the fraction of the
global male population that is sunning
its balls i would say
the fraction is very small even if we
multiply
by 2 by virtue of the number i'll bet
all people tend to have
yeah and just one at a time maybe
to reduce the risk of burning um i would
say it's it's also probably lower now
than it would be during the northern
summer because there are fewer people in
the southern hemisphere and anyone
trying to sun one's balls in the
northern hemisphere at the moment is
likely to
freeze them off instead oh yeah yeah
absolutely that's a real risk
yeah yeah i imagine sure okay
next question for those doing a science
undergraduate degree what
non-science subjects would you recommend
as electives
i love this question um i mean most
schools
are going to constrain you right
um but and what you take
depends whether or not you can learn
from what you're taking depends so much
more at this point on
who's teaching it uh than on what it's
called
um because there's a in practically
every field there are yahoos
as you know as phd experts
but you know any form of art
including music and theater and such
behind my list
philosophy that's well done um but so
much
so much of it is badly done
i started out as a literature major and
um basically
took the reading lists and ran away at
the point that it became too postmodern
which was a mere two years later
but you know good good critical reading
of literature is extraordinary as well
and you know economics is super valuable
i know i'm missing a lot here um i
actually have a degree in anthropology
uh which when done well is brilliant
yeah but the problem with
uh econ and anthro
and all these things and literature the
problem is everything's done badly
i would say do something where you pick
up
a technique that you can take with you
all right something where you're
learning to
build to construct something and it's
something that you can
not drop at the end of the term but that
you can continue
doing so that basically you use the
environment
of school to give you the on-ramp to
something you would have difficulty
accessing
on your own but that then continues to
pay back for life
one thing i took in college that i loved
and haven't really had access to was
book arts printmaking
made broadsides for a couple of quarters
and you know it's just
you know actually laying movable type
and you know the sort of very meditative
and you know you recognize how your
brain is flipped around as you're trying
to lay this
thing in the trays they type in the tray
so that it will read correctly on print
but
um you know that that was one of these
classes that i never
really thought a lot about in advance um
sort of happened into it because where i
was at that point had a
really great print making studio and it
was
it allowed sort of privacy and
meditation and art and i could you know
create my own prose and poetry that i
then laid into type and could you know
really reflect deeply on whether or not
my
my words were were good enough to
warrant the investment of time of
actually laying the type or if or
you know if actually this was just um
the you know ramblings of an 18 year old
and and didn't warrant it um so it um
the
that sort of activity too um can be
surprisingly
rewarding even though it's obviously you
know the work of a luddite at some level
you know no one needs
uh to work with mobile type anymore but
it's beautiful you know i
just i have a particular font as for
letterpress and the way that it feels
you know the the heavy the heavy paper
and the and the impressions it leaves
um are unique you don't get it with
standard printing
i'm thinking drawing for those of us who
don't draw that
that's a skill that shows up in all
kinds of places and if you can
get somebody to you know get you off the
foothill
uh it would be um
super useful i wish i had it yeah
wonderful okay i've got a bachelor's of
science
i'm not sure exactly what this question
means but we will
intuit uh we will interpret it as we can
i've got a bachelor's in science in
natural history illustration
and i'm trying to get into a
bio-veterinary science bachelors of
science at 23.
is this wise wanting white nose syndrome
how do i otherwise best study wildlife
diseases
so i think there's just like a missing
word or a misspelled word here but i
think i think this is reference to
white nose syndrome which is a fungal
infection that
many north american bats now have and
it's it's more than decimating
many bat populations um
i don't understand why why what white
now syndrome is doing in that question
right i i don't either i
think what is meant is
this person is interested in studying
white-nose syndrome
um although i may have that exactly
wrong um so
and you know how do i otherwise best
study wildlife diseases
you know i mean wildlife wildlife
biology wildlife science it goes by
different names in different schools
um but is different from bio-veterinary
science and man you know we need we need
veterinarians um but that field has
become
as pharmaceutically driven as medicine
uh and even harder to make a living at
i think because people don't tend to
have insurance for their pets
so it's it doesn't
look like a career move that is nearly
so
rewarding as it used to be unfortunately
do you have anything more here um
nope i'm still puzzling over i mean i
certainly think natural history
illustration is is important
i yeah i don't have anything to add
really
imagine we could add a critical thinking
class into the high school curriculum
what tools or lessons would you like
students to walk away with thank you for
your very insightful responses to my
questions
uh i would say um
there i hesitate to say there is only
one skill but
there is one focus which is the ability
to take on an argument so well that you
can deliver it whether or not
it matches what you actually believe to
be true
and sort of steel manning whether you're
in a scientific context or a
philosophical context or a political
context
is the thing that trains your mind uh
for analysis better than anything else
because
um you know you decamp
and in camp if that's the alternative uh
into these different perspectives and
because each of them has a large
framework that goes with it the ability
to activate them
uh you know at will
is uh it makes you mentally nimble i
think
so i never had access to and almost
certainly would not have chosen to do
what you did in high school before you
came to the high school where we met in
11th grade
um but you want to speak just briefly to
you know
we didn't have critical thinking classes
i mean we both went to
you know ultimately the same and earlier
different high school that were in my
estimation so good at some at so many
things
um but you specifically learned the
skill that you were just talking about
in an extracurricular form yeah i did
speech and debate
and um there was
a way in which speech and debate was
terrific
training for thinking about just about
anything
there was also a way in which it was um
you know it's a it's an amoral weapon
and i have the sense that a lot of
people who did speech and debate
you know speech and debate are two
different things it's really debate the
problem
arises with and it's not all debate
there's different kinds of
of debate so oxford debate is the sort
of uh
ruthless teams of two uh
who do battle with each other um as
opposed to lincoln douglas debate which
is
uh individuals and
is gentler and
the problem is it's very useful to learn
the skills of
oxford debate but among the skills were
an argument you could make an argument
that was persuasive
while being wrong even though you knew
it was wrong
as long as the people you were making
the argument against couldn't spot it or
articulate what was wrong with it right
now on the one hand that's good mental
training on the other hand
in the context of a high school speech
tournament fine
in the context of people who will go on
to inhabit other roles
there's only really one role where you
want
that to exist i guess which is the law
but even there
you know it it
it's a frightening it's a frightening
tool and so anyway um
yeah i know it's immoral at best as you
said yeah um but anyway it's good
training for the mind but i wish it came
along
with something i don't even know what it
would be because the problem is that
the activity incentivizes
whatever works right and
that's not a good you know that's not a
good model if you're trying to build a
whole person who
knows what they can get away with but
shouldn't right
so anyway yes there's part of the answer
in speech and debate
but it's also a problem waiting to
happen in the
in the wrong hands it's very dangerous
and most people's hands are the wrong
hands and high school does nothing about
teaching you anything that would be
useful in restraining that
force
35 minutes okay we'll get two more here
and then we'll move to this hour
as questions might there be an
evolutionary benefit to remaining
technologically primitive
some recent reports indicate the amish
growing as a percentage of the us
population
albeit slowly well
i i had not heard that i'm curious if
it's if it's true
we didn't we didn't end up doing it uh
but uh
before we um wrote our book
uh i had in mind a chapter um
which was going to start as an essay
called all the are the amish right
right and this was long before there
would have been any evidence that they
are right by virtue of their population
growing
but the basic question is um
if you recognize what technology will do
if you just keep pursuing it
then is there a point at which you stop
arbitrarily and voluntarily
and you know what is the consequence of
that and
there are two ways to be right really
you can be right that you should step
off the treadmill somewhere because if
you keep
going it'll kill you right or you can be
right about the particular place that
you can take technology and then bail
out right
and so they could be right about one and
not the other
um but not the other not the one
they could be right about neither no i
mean you can't you can't know where to
step off but not know to step off yeah
that's true
that's true um so anyway yes i think
there's a way in which they're no
they're
clearly right we are hurting ourselves
so terribly you know
with new technologies that have complex
consequences that
make us unhealthy in all kinds of ways
and you know it is
unclear yet whether we will figure out a
way to rein that in
um they're they're living the kind of
response
globally that we suggest for many
particular instances
that come with the words precautionary
principle
or chesterton's chesterton's fence right
these are these are exactly the
principles that um
i presume without formalizing it in any
sort of amish tomes
are are what this you know and you know
luddite is another
another of these terms that um describes
you know what
no this this this looks this looks like
we're going to go over a waterfall so
we're going to pull out now yep i think
also um
one has to imagine that at the point
this decision was made
it was contemporary right and so no more
you know at the point you have a phone
and you've got a buggy but you don't
have a motor car
right um saying well we're done with
this
and then it becomes more and more
anachronistic yeah
so it raises it raises those questions
um but i would also say that there is a
kind of there's clearly a kind of wisdom
associated with the choice because
the rum springer tradition which i
assume is
arose early recognizes
that it is not a slam dunk right and
that basically if you forbid
the young to engage the modern world the
modern world will be irresistible
and if you build in the encounter with
the modern world
and you give time to live as a modern
and then you come back or you don't
so rum springer being something like you
didn't define it so i'll
i'll try but i may have the details
wrong uh
something like every amish child at the
point that they are i don't remember 17
18
19 something is allowed to take a year
out of outside of the amish community
and go live
among the moderns and then at the end of
the year and i may have the
the details wrong they they either come
back or they don't
but if they don't after some prescribed
amount of time they don't
retain the ability to come back 5 10 20
years later
the door closes um not after a week or a
month
after a considerable amount of time but
it will close
yeah um and i think you know how how
incredible um to to tr to to
to be in such a constrained community
and to trust your children
with it yeah now if we have the details
wrong i would imagine that our
show is actually pretty popular in many
amish communities
i hope they'll contact us maybe maybe
someone on rum springer will
uh send us a super chat postcard wow
um oh this next one is just a uh a
recommendation
for a guest please consider inviting
british evolutionary biochemist and
writer nick lane
from ucl for a discussion about aging he
has written at length about its
evolution
and the influence of the hayflick limit
telomeres and the role of mitochondria
and oxygenic stress
on aging all right all right we will add
that to
oh and here's just one more suggestion
please consider inviting this week and
virology host
i should know how to pronounce this name
i've listened to a few of them but
vincent
ratzeniello to discuss coveted vaccines
thank you kindly
all right um super chat messages from
this hour
evolutionarily why is skin color color a
blend of both parents whereas eye color
is not
does eye color have to be sneaky to
avoid social judgment
or is it because eye color impacts
survival less than skin color
this is echo asking the question um and
it's it's terrific um so you know she
goes right to the ultimate level uh
rather than
sticking with the approximate level like
well you know eye color
is you know simple mendelian genetics
and
yeah um and i think i think the ants
i've never
i'd never asked the question before i
never considered it but
i think this is it because eye color
impact survival less than skin color
is is likely to be it
right that um two parents with
skin that works in the environment in
which they
conceived you a blend of those skin
colors should work well in the
environment into which you were born
whereas eye color has aside from totally
pigment pigmentless eyes eye color has
very little um to say about
um survival i would say certainly in
terms of sun exposure and
burning yeah i think i would put it a
little bit differently and i would say
there is a an advantage and the
advantage
may not uh be to the individual in fact
it probably isn't
um but there's a lineage level advantage
to having variation in skin color
that can be modified based on exposure
because basically we know that melanin
in the skin
is sunscreen and that the need for it
is something that varies with
environmental
conditions that change over space either
latitude or altitude or
clothing or various other things and so
um
basically why do you have
a many gene trait when it comes to skin
color
and a mendelian trait when it comes to
eye color
may be because there is value in
selection basically pushing skin
towards darkness or lightness depending
upon
where your population finds itself
and the fodder to do that has to do with
lots of genes rather than a small number
in which you would have
um a discrete distinction between
populations
yeah i think both of those things are
likely to be true yeah um that having a
a blend of your parents skin colors uh
will be a good match for the environment
in which they both exist and you were
conceived and born
and being multigenic presumably
facilitates the ability of skin to
change with sun exposure
yep good um
will cloth masks now be germ preservers
if they are stored in cold cars will
surface transmission be more likely with
germs kept alive through winter this way
so this question i think emerges from
the observation
that people are keeping
masks in their cars you know and never
take them out and in some places
actually don't even take them out
uh to wear them they just live in the
car and then they will put them on if
they absolutely have to if they're if
they're required to
um which you know we we think
that um coal is going to preserve the
virus
um and doesn't this
effectively um create an additional
uh an additional problem in terms of
effectively storing the virus for
activation
well a couple things one um
i think we have learned and somebody
took me to task for my use of the term
fomite and in fact i looked it up to
make sure that i didn't have it wrong
and i did have it slightly wrong
the foamite is the surface itself rather
than the particle transmitted on the
surface oh is that right
yep i didn't know that i hope i now have
it right i'm going to look it up why are
you talking about
in any case here's the point i think we
know
an inanimate object or substance that is
capable of transmitting infectious
organisms from one individual to another
there it is yeah so i think that fomite
transfer
is not especially common
with covet 19 or sars kobe 2. yeah
and therefore the fact that you will
preserve
the virus in your car potentially on a
mask
doesn't increase the tendency to be
transmitted by a surface and therefore
if the
tendency wasn't very high yes this will
increase the duration over which it
could happen
but it might you know i mean a mask
if you have covid then your mask will
have covid
and it could last on there longer but
you're not going to infect you
so will somebody else be more likely to
be infected because the period of time
over which your mask is infectious goes
up yes arguably
not very high i wouldn't think the other
thing i want to know though
and this goes sort of into the biology
of cyrus kovi too
but i believe that the nature of
the um the viral
capsule here is
not that it is
membrane-based and therefore i wonder
whether
a freezing might
you know freezing below some level would
damage it probably not but it could
um and b the other thing about the cars
is that you're going to get oscillations
you're going to warm your car up
it's going to be good and toasty as
you're driving around then it's going to
cool off then it's going to warm up that
kind of thing tends to be very hard
on something like a microorganism yeah
the car isn't just cold unless you're
never ever in it if you ever drive it
you heat it right up right the chances
that you
said somebody could get infected getting
in your car after it sat in the driveway
for three days
is probably higher in the winter
but the warm cool cycles are probably
protective if anything yeah that's good
i hadn't hadn't occurred to me i think
that's right
i so admire your equanimity and
integrity coupled with your incisive
brilliance
to what do you each attribute this
unusual confluence of virtues
well thank you yeah it's kind of a hard
question answer yeah it is
um
well i will say this the
many of the rare useful characteristics
in life
are rare because the thing that would
cause you to discover that they
work is not common the conditions in
which it is revealed that this is
um a valuable thing so to take one
example
the experience of publicly
advocating for a an analytical
perspective
and then coming to understand that
something about it was wrong
and finding the strength of character to
say
that it was wrong publicly is
all necessary before you discover what
happens downstream of that right
what you get is oh it's great to have a
voice that does
that that actually goes back and fixes
the thing that they said that was wrong
and so you actually paradoxically you
don't like
discovering that you were wrong and
knowing that you have to say things
publicly but once you do it you realize
oh
actually it reinforces something that's
even more important than being right
about the particular point
now it would be easy to learn the wrong
lesson there and it would be easy to
think oh being wrong is
not that bad i'll just go correct it
later and the problem is if you're doing
that too often then people discount what
you say
because although they realize you have
the integrity to correct it it means
that you're not doing a very good job of
quality control on the front end
so anyway the point is that whole
landscape of what happens when you're
wrong
based on what you do about it then is
hard to find the first few times and
then once you've found it it's like oh
you just
get good at trying not to be wrong and
when you're wrong doing the right thing
about it
so anyway i guess my point would be
unusual developmental experiences that
rewarded weird stuff
the extent that this question has an
answer it's that you want to provide any
specificity
as to um what the weird stuff was that
was rewarded
um for you you just said unusual
developmental experiences that rewarding
that reward weird stuff or you just want
to leave it at that
yeah i mean i i do i yeah i can't i
can't parse it
um i may be given some thought i could
come up with
yeah i mean i could come up with things
for you but uh maybe i won't
do what you think is right well um i
mean i think
there are a number of things we've
already talked about um you know debate
for instance um and you
had a grandfather who took
up uh apparently risky
uh experiences like skiing and climbing
mount whitney with you
you know in the 60s in his 60s rather
not the 60s you weren't born until the
very end um
and um and yet he had a reputation for
extreme
caution um and almost for you know
almost for you know lacking courage and
yet
um safety nut safety nut right and he
you know he
he was both extremely careful and
cautious
and and driven to explore and to take
risks that seemed worthwhile
and you got to spend a lot of time with
him and
you know that just even even just those
two things together and there are of
course
many more i think in your case um you
were also
extraordinarily informed by um
school and you having no fondness for
one another whatsoever
and um and you know i i had a
completely different trajectory uh with
also
um some you know inputs from you know
very you know rigorous scientifically
engineering um impacted
uh people and also at the same time
some very artistic influences and the
combination of having spent time with
literature and lots of different kinds
of
arts and um and and
both of us got to travel some um for the
most part my travel was
was domestic as a child um but not
entirely and just being able to see
different ways
that people did things and interpreted
what they did as
um as as young people was uh
extraordinary i i think
i think something that was super
important um was
we met when we were 16 actually in 11th
grade
and became friends very quickly uh and
it quickly became clear to me
that you had showed up in my awesome
school because you've been booted from
your
former school you had been invited to
leave and you were brilliant
and i thought i think i thought i don't
remember thinking this but i imagine i
thought
um boy i thought boys who got booted
from fancy schools were slackers who
really weren't doing much and that was
obviously a hundred percent clear from
the beginning that that's not who you
were
and i don't know if you thought about me
who was an ace student all the way down
i kind of thought a students were boring
generic rule followers who just
liked the comfort of authority which was
never who i was either
so we got to be friends um very quickly
you know we didn't we didn't get
together romantically for for several
years
um but could without ever saying it to
one another i think just recognize
similarly interested in open
questions minds who had had
wildly different developmental
experiences in terms of being rewarded
by
a structure in my case and being almost
completely
punished by the same structures in your
case
yeah i think uh there's a lot there's a
lot there and
um you know you were a paradox because
yeah um because on the one hand you were
very good at the exact stuff i was not
good at
right the school stuff um on the other
hand you were very unconventional
already and i think
you know it took me years to understand
exactly how that had happened but
had a lot to do with um
you having uh you know tomboy kind of
instincts toward the world
your dad having been a very unusual
guy you know in some ways he was a very
traditional
man's man um but you know i think
uh upon discovering that he had a
daughter who
uh you know shared his sort of desire
for adventure and
math competition yeah was perfectly
uh happy to mentor you in a way that he
probably didn't expect he would be
mentoring a daughter
and so anyway yeah uh
when when we met it you know it was an
issue of like
trying to resolve that paradox um
i will say that the school i got kicked
out of was uh
the all-boys school and i entered that
all-boys school at exactly the wrong
development in seventh grade
and in seventh grade where i hadn't
really gotten comfortable with the idea
of girls and then suddenly they didn't
exist in my universe and so i developed
a kind of
fear of them that was pretty profound
and then well it didn't show when we met
well it didn't show but i mean it didn't
show specifically because you were
unusual um so
it was you know so anyway that uh that
broke through
the um the fear that i had of girls
because it somehow didn't apply to you
but
anyway i'm glad that all happened on me
too yeah
all right all right um
i've told my nurse sister-in-law about
the loudly hypothesis and she looked at
me like i was
crazy why are healthcare professionals
brainwashed
yeah i think there's a good answer to
this question oh is there yeah i mean
it's not
a hopeful answer to this question but
there's a reason and it has to do with
the fact that so much in the area of
medicine
involves um falseness
that is generated that needs to be there
in order to do the work yeah and
therefore you get used to
the thing that makes those decisions so
that the maximum amount of medical good
happens telling you what the conclusion
is
and to you know if you go into that
scenario
with the kind of mind that says really
do we know that
they have the data on that you know
right if you're doing that you'll drive
yourself insane and so i think the
environment kind of selects for
somebody did the work they came to the
conclusion
it's my job to take that conclusion and
go wield it well
and then at the point you get to
something like you know covid
lab leak vaccine safety all of these
things and the point is you have
you have loons questioning all of it you
have responsible people
questioning all of it nobody can be
terribly sure of a lot of the things
that you would need to be absolutely
sure of to do
the analysis very well so there's noise
in everybody's analysis
that basically you've got a choice
between well somebody's done that work
and here's the conclusion and it's
you know what this laboratory you think
this came from you know
no this came from nature it came from
bats right so that
conclusion has been fed down the line
with a bunch of
sort of standard overly simplified
medical stuff and well like that i think
yeah being in medicine requires a
certain amount of
not questioning everything
on exercising differently indoors i
recommend checking out katie bowman's
nutritious movement work based in
washington
love to see a conversation between you
all i'm not familiar
uh we'll put it we'll put it on the list
risky hypothesis blm and trans are
allied to their reliance on postmodern
thought
trans especially with actual transition
is a triumph of narrative over reality
a fundamental proof that post-modernism
works
yeah now i i think that's right
and i do think that um
the trans people who we have known
who are really truly trans um
do not pretend that sex isn't real and
that they have actually
um transitioned into becoming the
opposite sex
so um you know the the triumph of
narrative of a reality that accompanies
many modern transitions is this weird
modern instantiate instantiation that is
indeed postmodern but is not inherently
what
um feel what being gender dysphoric
is about yeah i would add this
seems to me in the same neighborhood as
as what i've been arguing about
the online environment that in fact
the postmodern rules are not far off
of legitimate rules in an online
discussion space
in other words if i come into an online
discussion space
and i say i'm a woman then
a there's no reason for which you cannot
treat me as one
there is no justification for your
failing to treat me as one
right if i come into that space um then
at some level if i say i'm a woman you
should
go with that and the problem is this
logic only goes so far
it does not extend to a bathroom to a
prison
to sports that are segregated by
sex and so anyway my my sense is that
the
correct rules for how to deal with
people online
are simplified because the online
environment is already
bottlenecked to a very limited kind of
interaction
and that it is when you attempt to take
those rules and impose them on the
outside world that you run into all of
the paradox and you drive people crazy
because
if you're saying a man can become a
woman because he says so
and i'm a biologist do i hold my
biologist's tongue
or do i point out that you've just said
something it doesn't make sense right
i'm stuck and so your feeling is well no
we've worked this out online
right we just if somebody says they're a
woman they're a woman well what part of
you doesn't get that that's the right
thing to do
the truth may be you know what the
stakes were lower and it wasn't worth
anyone's time
also because you'll throw a mob at them
well i think the thing is
it's a hundred percent social and not
physical online
so therefore that simplified environment
being one where the only important
consideration
you know mind you we could figure out
stuff for which it wouldn't be the only
consideration but in a discussion forum
the only real consideration you know how
do you even know who you're interacting
with online
somebody says they're female you're
gonna how do i know you're really female
it's like
well you know we're talking about
geology
if i say i'm female i'm female right
um so well i mean i
obviously it can be gamed and yeah we've
we've talked about
um at the moment you know in the past uh
if social media had existed 100 years
ago
a woman might be pretending to be a man
just to have a voice yeah and right now
a man might be
pretending to be a woman to get voice in
certain
in certain um sub sects on social media
and so you can you can game the uh
the norms of the moment uh and
um and that that doesn't help anyone but
the individual gaming it
to what degree does it hurt the wider
population less so than in physical
space
um but still potentially harms it yeah
it means the integrity of it i i do
think you can
you can push things and find examples
where it's not true i'm just saying an
informal space online the postmodern is
actually
it's a it's an environment with no
physics and so
yeah because it's an environment with no
physics you can kind of set the rules
and to the extent that the rules might
be common courtesy rules
then okay problem solved um and that's
that's my
sense is that it is the um
false proof you know it's like it's like
burning man right
burning man to some people they think
man they think it proves that we can
have some sort of
utopian non-economic interaction with
each other where people are good and
artistic and generative
and there's no conflict and do people
really think that
they claim not to and then you push them
on and it turns out they do believe it
and they don't realize
you know what burning man would be a
whole different movie if the food
stopped coming
into the desert because nothing's gonna
grow there and you know so yeah
anyway like that yeah or um yeah bring
in
bring in everything you got and now live
there for a year
as opposed to a week or whatever it is
right whatever it is that imposes
conservation laws is going to cause a
whole different scenario to unfold which
doesn't mean you couldn't build a
civilization that would do
many of the things that burning man uh
does but you can't just wish it into
existence yeah
an hour okay let's get through i don't
know four or five more okay
speculative question what do you suspect
the role of psychedelics played in our
evolution and development
uh we've talked about psychedelics a few
of a few places
um almost no
many many cultures have some form of
psychotropics psychedelics hallucinogens
and theogens pick your pick your word
or a behavior that triggers these things
or behave sweat lodges and such uh
ecstatic dancing for for days on end um
yeah so the pursuit of ecstasis um and
psychedelics is
more than adjacent to to that um
is i think probably universal in
cultures
um and has
well you just looked like do you have
something to say
i got things to say okay you were headed
somewhere go for it
oh all i was gonna say is
riffing off of what you were getting at
it's so common
in various cultures that we have to
assume that this is something that human
beings
regularly discover and that they engage
when they have
when a culture has availed itself of the
power to do this sometimes it's limited
to one
group within a culture a shamanistic
class
but basically it's a
it's a hack where you can access parts
of
uh the product of your subconscious mind
you can put your conscious mind in touch
with it and
that's a very generative thing that at
some level it's like turning up the
um the mutation rate
on a genetic system you're turning up
the equivalent of the mutation rate or
the porousness of a boundary within the
consciousness system
and it results in you know yes that's i
like that the poor it
expands it enhances the porousness of
the boundary of some consciousness
system
it may increase individual consciousness
but also
increase the ability for actual exchange
across the interpersonal boundaries
absolutely and you know
there are lots of such hacks leaving a
notebook by the side of your bed and
writing down
the content of your dreams is a hack
right you're
wired i have an interesting point about
this at some point but
you're wired to forget the content of
your dreams
right now you're not wired to forget the
content of every dream but you're
wired to forget the content of most of
them and so you can hack that system
by taking the little period of time in
which your memory of the dream
evaporates and using it to write down
enough of the dream that you can recover
something meaningful from it
that's a hack and psychedelics
and other behaviors that cause those
hallucinations do the same
same kind of trick just gaining access
to something that is ordinarily
outside the scope of what you can can
contact
yeah so with regard to um what role they
may have played
long term it's impossible to know they
don't you know they leave no trace
in the archaeological record as far as i
know i don't know of any
um suggested trace in the archaeological
record but
um it is it is therefore mere
untestable arm waving to propose
something like
psychedelics may have been um
part of what the expansion the
prefrontal frontal lobe
was about we can't possibly know
well they leave some record what kind
uh for example the
mazatec people and
salvia salvia
is a plant only known if i've got this
right
only known from mazatech gardens
so salvia is a giant genus you're
talking about the particular
salvia divin oops
the hallucinogenic one okay um
yes the street name is salvia that tells
you anything divider sage yeah diviner
sage
uh salvia divinorum um is only known
from this plant grown by the mazatec
and that tells you that basically you
have a speciation event whatever its
nearest
uh relative is in the mints
this mint is now
exclusively a cultivar it's like a um
it's like a domestic goat you know there
are goats in the world but it's
it only exists in the context of people
um and so anyway but you're not
recommending smoking goats
uh smoked goat can be good it's
different
yes it is different um but anyway the
point is that's leaving a record because
what you've got
is you don't have the fossil that's
awesome yep um but you have the
product you know you have the
descendants of the most recent common
ancestor
and you maybe could i mean you could do
an attempt at a molecular clock to
assess the speciation event that the
time
since um this was uh since this
split from its most recent or from its
sister taxon which i don't know what it
is i don't know if the work has been
done and of course it's different in
plants and animals
um to do that kind of work
so well actually it's so i just pulled
up wikipedia
uh so who knows but botanists have not
determined whether salvia divinorum is a
coltogen or a hybrid
because native plants reproduce
vegetatively and rarely produce viable
seed
um so i know either either way
um really it's
well yeah either way it's leaving the
record of some kind of an event that we
don't have a direct record of
yes yes okay back to
super chat questions where i appear to
have
oh my goodness i think that was the
question we just answered and now it's
blank
the hallucination question is now blank
um
spooky a little bit i don't know what
this is this next one hey bretton
heather do you have thoughts on alpha
fold two
what is that i have no idea um no we
don't i'm going to assume it's a movie
and my sense is uh it was poorly cast
hi guys i'm from south america and i
notice an increasing trend in media
to promote witchcraft especially its
relation with feminism here in the us
oh yeah why are we witnessing this
return to paganism
um because life is too easy
and so people have
foolish ways of looking at the world do
better than we
would expect them to i don't know i mean
we've seen it here too we saw the new
york times uh in its front page section
with a
apparently serious article on a
self-described
which there is something i think it's um
you know
yeah i mean edgy uh it's edgy i think
it's
imagined i mean you know i have
i did have one student who was quite
seriously a wiccan
who i who i was close with and
i understood it to be a tradition that
that particular
person and their mother if i remember
correctly
um you really found community in and
meaning and this was a a
really good evolutionary biology student
who you know
was not was not woo-woo
but i don't love this language but
identified as wiccan
yeah um so you know i'm not
saying that this is always the case but
i do i do have the sense that because
witchcraft is is female and we are now
in this mode of um adulating all that is
female and finding the traditional ways
of being female that we have
to love that with that comes this really
uninvestigated oh well women are doing
it let's
let's let's celebrate it it's like okay
why
are we talking why why is everyone
always talking about
astrology now and witchcraft and
astrology is not
specifically female and um i'll just
leave a little teaser here that actually
astrology
could be done right uh with um and i
think we've actually talked about it
here before but i'm just not gonna go
there now
um but it it never is in
uh in in the modern environment but i
feel like witchcraft is just
like a thing that is so distinctly
female that
uh people are latching onto it as ah see
we're celebrating women
like no you're celebrating something
that's kind of daft what are you doing
yeah i agree and you know as with the
case
of astrology
you could encode patterns
that are real in a form that was
non-literal
and you know build community around it
yeah maybe
i mean we're some to the degree that
witches have existed in history i just
don't know anything about the history of
witchcraft
um but might some of them have been
ethnobotanists like the actual
um you know cures of of their
neighborhoods who really understood the
local
plants and fungus that could could
actually help people
i bet they were i'll bet this was some
you know sort of
female wisdom of of health um
and an environment that was then wrapped
up in
in witchcraft but you know modern modern
instantiations of this that involve
sitting around in people's you know east
side
manhattan apartments and claiming to be
witches not so much yeah which is what
that new york times article was about
yeah i remember
i remember okay uh
three two more um
i am a kiwi where we have public health
care and have also lived in the uk
with national health service the waiting
times in bureaucracy also kill people
a bias towards public rather than
individuals also kills people
oh true um you get a trade-off
and you know what you want is a proper
dispatch dispassionate net analysis
which we are never allowed to have
because one side or the other is always
punishing you for
pointing out the awkward truths that go
in the other direction
yeah i've had it we've got to find a way
to have these discussions because
pretending that there is not a
discussion to be had is
very unpleasant at the very least and
dangerous
um okay two more because one is just a
comment um that was also from the first
hour that i didn't get to can we just
agree that these labels are problematic
uh with regard to our discussion of the
you know far right
far left stuff why not look at the only
two that matter adults versus children
the group identity game is childish
um yeah now i'm not convinced that you
you know
in fact i will say boy i've forgotten
the name
of the second author on the
um the high quality analysis anna
zaitsev
and anna zaitsev anna zaitsev
sites in one of the places that i was
looking into her work
the political compass describing it as
is this so
this wasn't coming up before is this is
her this is her medium piece
yeah yeah uh yeah scroll down zach if
you just want to show this
oh yeah no i've lost it
yeah oh there it is political compass
moral foundation's jonathan height so
anyway um
i think the point is look political
compass ain't perfect but yeah it's a
whole lot
better than a one-dimensional analysis
right now i've argued somewhere else i
can't remember where it was but i just
ran into it
that the political compass is still
flatland right
it's two-dimensional but it's flat land
and that there's a z dimension and of
course
the question is how many dimensions
could you add
and be more productive than you are
destructive
but in any case there are useful labels
and we have to remember that every time
we create a label it has
a upside and a downside
and we want labels that pay their
freight and then some
but we want never to forget that each
time you draw one of these distinctions
you're going to have arbitrary stuff at
the boundary
so anyway you know yes adult versus
children is a useful one very hard to
operationalize
yeah because it's not a matter of age
anymore really
um but yes okay one more and
uh next week we will start with this
question about the great reset
um that came in very late here okay our
final pro
question for today is hey guys what's
the word on deepmind's protein folding
breakthrough
yes and i'm wondering is that what alpha
fold 2 was about yeah i'm thinking it
was
yeah i thought so at the time but i
wasn't sure okay
um different person uh terrifying
i find it terrifying i i wouldn't say
that i i
first of all wait wait you need we i you
need to say what this is
okay there has been a long running so
there's a long-running problem in
biology
which is that genes encode
proteins proteins are long strings of
amino acids
those strings of amino acids don't do
anything what happens is they collapse
into machines that do things and we're
talking about literal
machine-like entities you know
nucleotide bases
uh
what are we talking about no the genes
aren't made of amino acids
no the genes aren't but they encode
these strings of amino acids which
collapse
into machines which do stuff okay
the problem is that there are an
indefinitely large
number of conformations that these
strings of amino acids could collapse
into and if they collapsed into all of
them they wouldn't work
in fact they would never work but they
don't collapse into all of them they
collapse into forms that do things
and in fact these forms are sensitive to
things like the temperature so one of
the reasons that a small fever
can actually you know a fever of five or
six degrees fahrenheit can be lethal
is that your enzymes only have the
proper confirmation to do their job
at that temperature and so as you change
the ph or change the temperature
the positive charge here that sticks to
the negative charge there
if you put in too much energy it breaks
and so the enzyme doesn't work
so in any case well and also i mean that
that folding structure you know the
technical term
being denatured it just starts to to
come undone
right at temperature and so the
denaturing of a protein
means that nothing on the surface of
that protein looks the same as it does
when it's in its normal range
right but you know you could have two
different creatures you could have a
creature whose normal temperature
was 102 fahrenheit another creature for
which it was 98
right and the enzyme for the one at 98
won't work at 92
and vice versa so denatured is one way
to say it but the point is
outside of a narrow range for an
endotherm no
for a uh
homeotherm the
range for viable temperatures for that
enzyme will be relatively narrow
and anything outside of it or a change
in ph will cause the
parts of the string of amino acids that
bond to some other
part through these hydrogen bonds will
change and any change in the outside
structure will initially decrease the
effectiveness of the enzyme
and then eventually make it not
effective at all
so anyway the point is how these things
fold up into some structure that is
reliable and does the job
is a very long-standing very difficult
problem like 50 years we've
been aware of this problem and made not
that much progress yeah figuring out the
list of amino acids in the order they're
in
is is child's play by comparison right
right we can get the sequence but then
the point is okay if i show you a
sequence
what's it going to turn into a smart guy
you know and it's like well
we generally don't know um so it's the
primary structure is the string tertiary
structure is the
conformation and then quaternary
structures you add multiple
proteins together what's secondary ah
i don't remember oh it's beta sheets and
oh yeah so
bigger level of folding yeah so
secondary and tertiary are both folding
yeah but anyway there's been this
long-standing contest
to try to spur progress in this field
which is we give you a sequence you tell
us how it's going to fold up
and this year huge progress was made by
deepmind which is
google's artificial intelligence uh
platform um and basically the idea was
that
somehow deepmind has it has come close
to solving the protein
folding problem if the date if the
result holds up and we don't know that
it will
because frankly it's not a published
paper
so we can't really look at it we can see
you know
here's the sequence they were given
here's the
prediction and here's what the actual
confirmation of the thing looks like
but it's not like we have a full
analysis to look at but it
looks incredibly promising now the
interesting part of it i think
is i think it implies
that the problem is simpler than we
think which it almost has to be
because for evolution to successfully
navigate the
that's how you evade terrifying
kind of yeah kind of but so if you
imagine that in or
you know the thing that we say in
biology which you and i have been
ranting about for a long time
we say oh you have genes
mutations happen all the time most of
them are bad some of them don't have any
effect
every so often just by random a gene
happens to
get changed in a way that increases the
blah blah blah blah blah
and suddenly you have ostriches right
and the answer is
actually that's too weak a process to
create these marvelous little machines
um what's more these marvelous little
machines
altering them slightly by this mechanism
doesn't
change you know one kind of amphibian
into another
and so there's a whole bunch of the
story that doesn't quite add up and it's
missing and
you know i'm firmly committed to the
idea that what's missing is darwinian
too i'm not arguing
that this is a challenge to darwinism in
any serious way i think we need
more and better darwinism but
nonetheless
if it is true so the explorer mode thing
that i keep getting in trouble for
explorer mode thing suggests that
selection will
will very quickly discover mechanisms to
search design space more efficiently
than it could at pure random
right that's not a mystical claim that's
not a designer that's selection
cheats by figuring out selection will
have heuristics yeah exactly that's
that's what you're arguing
right now the reason that comes up here
is because
chances are and i don't know that we
know because the way these deep learning
algorithms
figure out how to solve a problem
doesn't necessarily tell you what
they've discovered
right what i suspect has happened is the
deep learning algorithm
has latched on to the product of the
heuristics and started to go backwards
and so the point is to this extent that
there are
patterns there are themes in the folded
up proteins
that would be the result of a heuristic
that searches only here and here
not all the intervening space that deep
mind would be in a better position to
spot that thing and that
ultimately it will tell us what we
didn't know about the way design space
is
searched right so in some sense i i
think this is potentially really
interesting that's
amazing uh that's yeah that's that
that doesn't sound as terrifying um
and it put me in mind of this isn't
i don't i don't think i can exactly go
full circle on this
but it put me in mind of the heuristics
that we are familiar with from
systematics from
from how it is that we inferred deep
history how it is that we build
evolutionary trees and
um and deduce uh who's most closely
related to whom
uh because once you've got more than you
know a few taxa with a few characters
each
uh you basically can't you you can't
search
all of the possible tree topologies in
any reasonable amount of time even with
the computing power that we have now
and so you have to you know basically
different software
uh different phylogenic systematic
software is going to be using different
heuristics and the heuristics are
generally
generally not public and so you don't
you pick a piece of software and yes you
plug in different assumptions and
hopefully as few as possible
and you end up with a set of most likely
trees given your particular data set but
in that case you don't have anything to
compare it to like maybe
you compare it over here using this data
set and over here using this data set
and maybe with a couple of different
pieces of software
but because we don't have time travel we
can't actually go back and know for sure
what the history of relationships is
whereas with this
you actually have the empirical answer
like what does the thing look like when
it's folded what does the protein
actually look like
let's see if deepmind got it right oh
they did and so fast
it did i don't know what deep mind's
pronouns are
that's a good question i wonder yeah
um i'm just i'm stuck to stop to my
tracks
by that question well i would stop my
drinks by calling into they so
yeah all right um yeah so anyway um
yeah look there's all sorts of reason to
be terrified about the amount of power
that we are gaining and the fact that we
will
almost certainly screw up the
application of
the technology that results but from the
point of view
of having a total head scratcher with
respect to how
proteins are going to fold up versus
having some window into the heuristics
um i'd say this one um we should be real
careful with that but
it could be awesome to discover what we
didn't know and my guess is there's
going to be a kind of a
eureka sort of a moment and yeah once we
figure out what d
d mine did okay well i hope i hope
you're right
it's rare that uh i'm more pessimistic
than you
yes let's let's hope you're right here
yeah all right all right i think that is
it for today wow right yep um
so uh consider going to
store.darkhorsepodcast
or either of our patreons where you will
get a
further discount off of store stuff if
uh
if you want brett has a conversation on
his patreon tomorrow for people at the
highest patron level
evolutionary discussion which i'm
looking forward to should be great from
10 to noon pacific time
uh you can access the discord server at
either of our patreons
what else are we supposed to say i don't
know maybe maybe that's it
maybe try to enjoy your december here in
the pacific northwest we've got
maybe maybe another hour or two before
it starts raining and we'll be raining
until april oh
terrible yeah i'm gonna get on my bike
yeah well you know what you
you two days in a row now one day
you bite down to the river and then up
to this peak
uh all in one ride but half of it in the
dark yesterday
right which is a which is a vertical
gain
1500 foot climb it was good
nice it was good the weather was
conducive yeah cold but clear
yeah yeah yeah so
all right so do that go outside yeah go
outside all right we will see you
uh next week be well everyone